Hello Hime desu ah
Thanks to you, my youtube channel has surpassed 1 million subscribers --
I think everyone knows that I love to talk about anime,
so the opening song, battle scenes, and my favourites.  The videos
I've collected The tag-sans are so delicious that people come here
every day. Since I created this channel 10 years ago, I've
posted over 6,500 videos, and the total number of views has reached a whopping 7!  Let's buy
it Everyone who subscribed to my channel Everyone who watched the
video with me Everyone who commented on the video Thank you from the bottom of my heart Thank you
For the next 10 years More every day  I will be posting more anime videos, so
please continue to support
me.